Ciao a tutti io sono Angelo Maggi
attore doppiatore direttore del
doppiaggio italiano
attore soprattutto
ma per quello che mi ha fatto risparmi
risparmi
al Serio
assorbito
il come non lo so
motivazione da amministrazione nei suoi
particolari
borderò
cominciava così il con questo monologo
lo spettacolo fa male il teatro che mi
vide de buttare la bellezza di 42 anni
fa E da allora ho fatto tantissimo
teatro con i più grandi ho deputato col
mio maestro Vittorio Gassman ma poi ho
avuto la fortuna di lavorare con
albertazzina
[Musica]
che cosa è successo una magia io entrai
in questa sala di doppiaggio e mi colpii
soprattutto
il buio Sì il buio questo questo la voce
Oltre il buio di questi attori
straordinari magari i miei coetanei io
vedevo mi diceva Mamma mia come sono
Bravi Io non potrei mai essere bravo
come loro e poi soltanto in un secondo
e poi con gli anni ho seguito una grande
direttrice dell'epoca Fede Arnaud e ho
doppiato i miei primi protagonisti Hugh
Grant in Notting Hill
Bruce Willis nel sesto senso è
finalmente Tom Hanks nella mia prima
volta con Tom Hanks nel film Cast away a
chi mi chiede
se preferisco tra le forme di
espressione
[Musica]
Ma le persone che sostengono che
un attore e un doppiatore è un attore a
metà Ecco io rispondo
parafrasando Il visconte di Italo
Calvino che non mi sento affatto un
attore dimezzato
io mi sento un doppio attore
deve essere un camaleonte
deve avere un grande orecchio anche
musicale e
un dovetone per eccellere Alla fine deve
essere rigore e sregolatezza
per la la la la la l'unicità che si deve
dare all'interpretazione che si fa
doppiando quell'attore per la tecnica la
tecnica del mestiere dell'attore
[Musica]
Ecco non mi sembra un po' la stessa cosa
che avviene nel doppiaggio di un attore
un personaggio nutrito di emozioni da
quell'attore una prima volta viene
successivamente nutrito una seconda
volta di altre emozioni quelle del suo
doppiatore attore interprete italiana
[Musica]
molto spesso
se ho conosciuto personalmente gli
attori che ho il comune
che non tutti hanno avuto il privilegio
di conoscermi
Vabbè sto scherzando ovviamente non è
facile che tutte queste grandi star
americane ti possono possono incontrarti
io però ho avuto la fortuna di di
incontrare di conoscere forse forse
l'attore che ho più volte doppiato
Insomma che ho avuto la fortuna di
doppiare più volte
ci siamo conosciuti a Venezia
e lui rimane bloccati in aeroporto In
termine per uno o hanno e lui poi Impara
la lingua e anche io ho fatto in
italiano miglioramenti dopo studiare
lingue inglese e io e italiano
insomma
a Venezia
Adesso non ricordo neanche più il film
della DreamWorks
anche
altri the post per esempio
quello che ha a che fare con un
raffreddore una bronchite che succede in
quei casi in sala di doppiaggio in quel
caso è intervenuto Per quanto mi
riguarda l'effetto C no Avete capito
tutti naturalmente e ho avuto a metà
film più o meno
in particola
[Musica]
sì Cioè se voi andate per esempio non so
a Parigi
[Musica]
incartapecorirsi dico io nell'attore che
dobbiamo quindi essere molto vicini nel
cartone animato è un po' più libera la
cosa ascoltiamo sempre quello che è
stato fatto dall'attore in precedenza
però siamo più liberi di creare una voce
è un po' quello che è successo a me con
me insomma
[Musica]
io a crescere con mio nonno bella di
nonna vieni qua tesoro
[Musica]
questa parlata napoletano
che ho fatto a Firenze
Vittorio Gassman il grande Eduardo De
Filippo
e Edoardo
mio nonno
Tutti vogliono un lieto fine
ma le cose non vanno sempre così
Forse stavolta
Spero che se ascolterete questo
messaggio sia per festeggiare Spero che
le famiglie siano riunite che si sia
ristabilita qualcosa che somiglia ad una
versione normale del pianeta
che mondo meraviglioso che universo
se mi avessero detto 10 anni fa che non
eravamo soli di altre forme di vita
figuriamoci non sarei rimasto sorpreso
Ma dai che si immaginava le forze epiche
dell'oscurità e della luce che entrano
in gioco
nel bene e nel male
questa è la realtà in cui Morgan dovrà
trovare il modo per crescere e così ho
pensato di registrare un salutino
in caso di una prematura di partita
la mia intendo
Insomma non che la morte sia sempre
prematura
il viaggio nel tempo che tenteremo di
fare domani mi sta facendo perdere il
sonno con questo fatto della
sopravvivenza
ma il compito dell'eroe è questo una
parte del viaggio e la fine
ma perché questo Trip
tutto quanto andrà esattamente come deve
andare
Ti amo 3000